les manifestants sont descendus dans les
rues de plusieurs grandes villes
indiennes pour protester contre les
propos d'un prisonnier condamné à mort
pour le viol d'une étudiante en 2012
nous protestons contre ce que raconte le
principal protagoniste dans un
documentaire il dit que le crime de viol
était la faute de la victime parce
qu'elle se promenait le soir dans la rue
nous voulons qu'ils soient pendus
maintenant en décembre 2012 à new delhi
la capitale six homme violent et tuent
dans un autobus de la ville une jeune
étudiante de 23 ans ce drame fera
descendre dans la rue des milliers de
manifestants qui dénoncent sort réservé
à trop de femmes en inde une
réalisatrice britannique fera un
documentaire de cette sordide histoire
en rencontrant dans sa prison le
principal coupable
il n'avait aucun regret aucun remord dit
elle pas un seul pendant les 16 heures
où je les rencontre et ils disaient
pourquoi fait-on toute une histoire de
cela alors que tout le monde le fait
selon le principal coupable et mukesh
singh que l'on voit ici d'un
documentaire une femme ne doit pas
sortir après 9h et la responsabilité
d'un viol incombe plus à la femme kahlo
la diffusion à la télévision prévu ce
dimanche journée internationale de la
femme a soulevé une vague d'émotion dans
le pays et au parlement indien
ministre de l'intérieur a déclaré avoir
interdit la diffusion du documentaire
craignons que les déclarations du
principal coupable ne crée à nouveau des
tensions et de la violence
bannir le film n'est pas une bonne idée
dit cette responsable d'un groupe
féministe surtout dans le contexte
indien et de la place des femmes dans
notre société
le viol collectif et la mort de la jeune
étudiante en décembre 2012 avait
profondément bouleversé la société
indienne depuis la loi sur les violences
sexuelles a été passablement durci mais
new delhi reste toujours la capitale du
viol en inde
oui le viol en inde est un véritable
fléau voici quelques chiffres qui vont
vous faire frémir en 2013 on ya recensé
près de trente quatre mille agression
sexuelle et ce ne sont que les cas
rapportés aux autorités ce qui veut dire
que chaque jour en moyenne 93 femmes se
font violer en inde c'est une femme
toutes les 15 minutes
de ce nombre une victime sur quatre a
moins de 18 ans une autre donnée très
troublante presque toutes les femmes
victimes de viols connaissaient leur
agresseur